Speaker 1: All right, this is a really serious
story. You know, we we talk about in the abstract
how this escalated course and more kind of
audacious and brazen extremist political
rhetoric that has really gone public in
a lot of ways since the start of Trumpism
has real world consequences. These people are
radicalized for real. And then they go out and
they do things in the real world. The Jan. six
Trump riots were a really great example of that.
These are people who in a great insignificant
proportion, existed online for a long time,
and then they went out on January 6th
and then they did horrible things.
Monday night there was a mass shooting that
took place in Denver. And it turns out that
the perpetrator and we really we have no, you
know, often in these things, we don't name the
perpetrator. But in this case, the perpetrator was
a known entity. The perpetrator was an individual
with a known public white supremacist alt
right, misogynistic. Platform or position,
we are learning more and more about this shooter.
Daily Beast article called Denver Gunman Left
Online Trail of Hate tells you a lot of what you
need to know. Linden McLeod, who police say killed
five people in Denver on Monday, was an author
dedicated to alt right philosophies, including
masculine supremacy, contrarian COVID beliefs
and targeted violence against the quote weak.
MacLeod appears to have operated a
plethora of Twitter and Instagram accounts
under the alias Roman Maclay, which he used for
his three book series Sanction. In his posts,
MacLeod seemed to frequently use excerpts
from his work to comment on current events,
such as a COVID misinformation meme on Twitter
featuring Facebook creator Mark Zuckerberg and
Microsoft founder Bill Gates. The meme featured
the billionaires discussing their approach to the
pandemic, with Gates being thanked for mandatory
vaccinations with Zapper. Zuckerberg congratulated
for a quote. Injectable nano worm MacLeod, who
was killed by a Lakewood police officer Monday
after shooting her in the abdomen, captured the
photo with a quote from one of his characters in
his book series. It's not really a worm so much,
however. I understand the point. He gleefully
indicated some people required violence to be
addressed while discussing the 2014 YouTube video
titled Mike Tyson Destroys Reporter on Twitter
MacLeod as his character as his persona, McLay
blasted the passive aggressive reporter and
praised Tyson for using direct aggression.
During a press conference Tuesday, police
confirmed that McLeod, who records showed
owned his own tattoo parlor, targeted each of
his victims. Right wing rapper and social media
personality, known as Zuby, hosted Maclay on his
podcast to discuss sanction in 2019. The host
claimed the book was blowing up Twitter, though
he admitted he hadn't read it. Police say during
a Tuesday press conference MacLeod previously
was investigated, but they didn't comment on why
Curt Barnes, a spokesman for the Denver police,
told The Daily Beast he was not aware of the
connection between McLay and McLeod, but would
forward the information to investigators. There's
a whole tweet history of this guy, including
there's a tweet from 2018 where Chloe Valdiserri
tweeted. Maya Angelou said that if a person
is told they are nothing, then they will say,
Oh, you think I'm nothing? I will show you where
nothing comes. Do you think it's coincidental that
at a time when the left is condemning whiteness,
neo-Nazi activity is going up on the right?
And Roman Maclay, which is believed to be
this guy's online persona, said Finally,
someone is saying this maybe Heather Hyang will
listen to you since she follows you. Good job
pain demands a response. All of us have limbic
systems and feel terrible when society hates us.
Invisible Man by Ellison or sanctions?
Same story. Different race. So an entire
an entire online history of this guy. Another one
of these instances where he wrote, I start with
sexual dimorphism for a reason. Biology is our
first clue. Then you look at thousands of years of
religions from Norse to Jew, Christian and Muslim
all demand female chastity. Then you ask modern
men how they perceive untraced women. Three levels
of analysis which align so like typical kind of
men's rights activist misogynistic stuff. So
what's the takeaway here? What's the lesson? The
lesson is that his fiction, the fiction that this
guy fell for was the foundation for his actions,
and this stuff has real world impact. Also
important, and I'm going to do this every
time we cover a shooting now. This was a
shooting on Monday. Got a lot of attention.
There were 110 other shootings on Monday. In
addition to this one, this is constant. This
is a constant backdrop. Check out the specifics
on gun violence archive.org. But this was one
shooting we talked about, and there were 110 other
shooting, not mass shootings, 110 other shootings
of different kinds. Some subset of that mass
shootings, it is a constant in the United States.